Day 36 in the hole it feels like I don't
know anything but the darkness yeah I
don't know what's going on eventually
we're gonna roll so there are two guys
out there that want to murder us yes
hello everybody welcome back to day 93
of rust
we've been stayed which which which day
is it
you know I I don't remember is more
we've lost count that's what day it is
we've been stuck trapped in here they've
since ceased communications to us but I
don't know how much longer we can go now
they know was just like [ __ ] out of my
chin this is my bit of a trigger finger
Oh crappy I guess I gotta get out of
here no I can you ever describe your
surroundings yeah [ __ ] you
your wildest imaginations you will
reward it yeah forgot we gonna come save
us strategy now is just wait in our box
battle master of this game comes and say
it's us yes the only person who's been
on our hide and this time is trigger
happiness will aid us ah
you think those guys are still out there
I you you go look oh not yeah right yeah
right yeah right you're a small time
compared to what we're facing
here okay oh I heard that did you that
ha ha is that good at diplomacy that's
good enough that's good enough I'm
surprised we got like the whole server
conglomerated on our location there were
only like 10 I mean there's no way for
people to know that markiplier is on
here mark
ha true dreamy I'm here what's out there
people what's out well I don't know but
they're guilty I I feel the guys you
killed two guys yeah kids the guy what's
his name I don't remember same should i
slam the door I heard him shooting out
here and I I
I don't know if we should open the door
know if we can trust him uh don't let
your stir craziness affect you he's our
ally mark I don't even know if I can
trust you right now uh I mean um you yes
you can come in but no wait no no no
okay then don't touch the door we don't
know wait no oh it's our friend yeah we
stay away you can open the door Matt
it's not wait it's Bob wait yeah hey
he's telling you only carefully they
come yeah I just didn't you get on
something come on in
oh did you die oh maybe yeah
no I kill the guy but you don't have any
stuff left are you could you put your
gun down
I'd be I know how to do wait no wait no
wait no we no wait ha ha well kill you
bro kill me bro ha ha ha yes that's guy
kill the games all day yeah
but you died didn't you because you lost
all your things look I think he just
took all this armor off to hang out this
oh ok yeah sure that's Hillary gate
awful we've been trapped in here is it
daylight out we don't know any we've
been trapped in here for like a month
even know what's happening yeah
also it's not daylight that's why it's
been like night forever much safer they
can't go in there
uh-huh okay okay held annoying we don't
we don't know what to do now though what
do we do what what do I do
take the metal ore in here if you have
any
uh-huh and then what like metal doors
and stuff if any can't get Raiders buddy
oh well no one's gonna get in which we
close the doors on the way out we're
smart heaven take a break in oh yeah
break it what are you talking about huh
I like this guy I'm breaking them it's
totally cool
yeah wait I hear someone everybody's
just be quiet I hear someone that's
turtle who truce gift what's a truce
gift it's gonna bullet to the face yeah
I don't need that we got a truce gift
for you too
it's messy for oh go away or are we
about to die that's important question
what ya gonna do they gonna just die
you're gonna die to keep it open
Oh hit oh well did you what is it no it
actually was a Triscuit he just gave us
six cooked chicken breast oh yeah he did
kill you Bob does that six chicken
breast meat make up for how you died I
mean I may have been in his house going
through all of his boxes trying to take
everything he owned yeah help me yeah
okay happened like what does it make it
up give you money you're allowed to go
where everyone yeah there's no rules in
this game you're the king they're the
Kings dear man yeah to do whatever you
want yeah
go kill him I say we should let him in I
says we should let him in let him in
anymore yeah we should let him in but
okay can't we just no can't we just know
keep your enemies closer than your
friends and you I would pay or my
frenemies should we let him in oh okay
we're gonna let you in are we just gonna
kill the [ __ ] out of you here no no I
don't think are you sure we're not gonna
kill the love you are not going to kill
you
I'm opening on my door ah oh come on
come on in come on in close door alright
okay alright yeah look at least we got a
club we got a club alright um put mark
are you the president of our club
apparently King apparently okay
as my first act as king we're gonna stay
in here and never leave because it's too
dangerous outside actually I don't know
what else to do what should we do can't
get why do you have a gun out
can't you put your gun away no I'm the
King here arc no oh okay oh no Bob no
we've been together for so long bob I'm
just jokin I'll kill you later
I just ate a ration it is really handily
you don't have a mic stirring you could
talk to you could get your voice on
YouTube and several hundreds of
thousands of people might hear it baby
you never know ignore all that stuff
about last time where we said we hated
you Bob shoot him Bob shoot him just now
I'll do it shoot him now
oh my god okay that was our street now
hotel that was for Bob no we're even
oh oh did body you'd all contorted a
dead leave it outside the door just in
case he wants to pick it up oh that was
beautiful
those two view that was really
satisfying it was wasn't it
we messed up way like that felt amazing
yeah this game is just messed up
politics man oh and it's almost day out
delightful so I like also how we just
sort of have a prisoner like you're
totally just stuck in here now yeah now
you're here for the King me could do it
like yeah oh you can't wait you can
suicide how do you suicide he's super
useful oh okay okay
f1 yeah don't do that now guy do it mark
do it f1 is suicide okay I want to do it
I want to do it I really want to do it
one and then time suicide okay okay
press f1 yeah then type suicide should I
do it Bob
who's outside you don't I'll kill you
I'll kill you oh no no who's there I got
it if that it's gonna break down the
door oh my god yeah for the killer hey
hey your pickaxe is outside man it's on
the other side
thank God Bob Cousy community blog open
the door
wait no I said that publicly up Susie
comes Marc I don't know over do it open
that door wait when did trigger get a
gun oh I was just knocking with her hey
hey hi hi when you get a gun what what I
had a gun all the time I don't have an
addict rate I don't believe that for two
seconds oh hey what the piece nothing my
own what's up Pete what's up Pete you
fifty boy that was a bad move triggered
something was a bad move no no no we
wouldn't kill you mark that's horrible
no I would not what's done is
interesting though did you like make
this or how do you get how do you get a
thing what ours is just called a
9-millimeter pistol yeah
yeah this one you can find blueprints
with yeah you take it back you take it
back
I think strudels out there strudel is
out there I'm going out strudels right
there right there
going out I'll cover you
hi strudel hey hey hey sorry about that
oh I'm so sorry we're all friends right
yeah so we're even now and so I'm not
gonna kill you anymore so we're friends
right that's fine yeah we'll stay away
from your house probably and you know
you don't like murder us or anything
anymore
that's fine uh-huh bark bark bark oh not
what you wanted I highly doubt that's
what he wanted huh
okay all right in a unicorn give a mark
you should make him in your eco unicorn
shooting in head instead oh that's a
great idea that's a really good way to
make friends let's do that uh they would
have a horn it would it be there pick
your words wisely Hey okay it's all
really close them and yes you in the
right in there okay uh will not die off
one bullet I think okay okay hello they
won't know come back we weren't trying
to kill you now no it's gonna rock
unicorn no we're just making you a
unicorn unicorn
you're a beautiful unicorn come back Oh
Bob I think you laughs horrible Bob okay
back to our talk all right time for us
to venture out on our own
hey yeah I'm gonna see if there's c4
placed on top of our uh our thing cuz
I'm pretty I'm pretty sure there is no
c4 up there Bob oh yeah there's no c4
we're good look I don't know how they
got up here hey he came back okay
journal Journal hi oh hey Bob see Bob no
more talking and game it echoes on - Gus
sound weird okay yeah happy nice turtle
sorry strudel tips on how to build our
base well we already know how to build
our base do you think weirdness we all
right we're pretty new queen don't need
your help we got this we got this one
luck
no shut up Bob we don't need any tips Oh
yeah you say that we're new a will give
you more than a unicorn horn give you a
holy man hmm okay
all right Bob I think this madness needs
to stop this madness t ha and this
madness he needs to stop I know is that
my better a really great idea is that do
you mean I should my oh you hear you see
my foot
I think they should look much better
they have a hole in him
uh no no hey Bob getting house don't let
him in the house okay Bob how do you get
in how did he win get out the crash yeah
yeah just me and Bob time okay okay all
right so anyway all right oh my god Bob
did he write it up here
ignore him bother been a fun adventure
hey wait wait wait wait wait what what I
think it's time for this to end
no no no no no no I think it's time for
this to end
no no I wasn't gonna kill you what are
you thinking I'm gonna kill you guess
you're talking like you're gonna kill
Bob it's time for this all to come to an
end
oh do you mean my life this is not worth
it it lower the survival is not working
out I'm not cut out to lead I'm not cut
out for it
Bobby I'm dead the pain are you sure
Bobby I've had the pain please I don't
know if I can
oh yeah what the fight what and there
lies the end of our adventures in rust
such that it was such that it were such
that it always will hey I'm back alright
hey hey gonna I'm talking about alright
but this is just the other part that we
got here so you [ __ ] hey that's
really fun I think this is gonna fill
our home with your bodies I think you're
the cool down to respondent I'm not in
camp anymore you dick I'm in a waiting
period to respond at camp
you bastard [ __ ] way to go I'm in the
middle no well I'll let you in I'm not
anywhere near there who are you talking
to
don't let them talk everyone's freaking
out over here
I killed mark but it's okay cuz go away
go but what and I think I'm nearby I'm
gonna come here god damn it Bob
all right so that's all the time we got
for this episode thank you all so much
for watching thanks Bob
for nothing and as always I we will stay
you in the next video
this looks really real
okay goddamn it Bob hey stop breaking
our house he's coming back I'm coming
back the house he's coming back coming I
think I'm in the near least that was
part of the video there was just a gag
don't worry yeah whoo there's nothing
there coming to get revenge on you
because you killed me don't kill me I
have a shotgun ha ha ha is this not is
how do you repair a door oh no no that's
not gonna you okay what Jesus God I
figured out how to repair a door in
seven days to die apparently if you
suicide mark you can respawn here can't
I okay we'll figure out oh there is a
console s1 is the console I still
excited oh look at that there's a whole
bunch of stuff in the console who's that
oh okay oh that's so weird oh my god you
could repair doors
oh my microphone that was very magical
how do you repair doors you you just
look at I'm not at a camp it's a five
minute cooldown
Vic and now I'm not close to where I was
anymore
ah Bob you have screwed me over that was
really cool I know the repaired or it's
not super useful how do you do that
Bob how do you do that what's on the
pickaxe Bob Bob why do I have to pick
yet I found a bigger oh yeah
strange apparently that's the super
useful skill thank you sure you're happy
okay I forgot your name
all right anyway so this is all the time
I think we're gonna end it like that's
enough for today
what do you think Bob I think we can end
it yeah yeah okay that was a good run I
really liked those last few episodes
yeah more you know I got really silly
with all the people and stuff I did it
was fun though
a pickaxe apparently can one-shot
zombies wow really yeah just kill them
instantly we try to find another one mmm
yeah one shot zombies bad bad all right
here we go all right I'm getting out of
this server